hello everybody good morning thanks for
coming to hear about chemical computing
which is kind of cool and I'm really
excited to share that with you all right
well let's get into it then so first
this presentation is rated G for general
programmers however there is a small
disclaimer there will be intense
sequences of lips code so you have been
warned this paper this presentation is
also starring the papers of chemical
computing by Peter ditrich higher order
chemical programming style and I'm not
sure there I'm pronouncing these names
right well do my best
JP Binaca p4 day and why rabbinic also
another paper by them is principles of
chemical programming and also
programming self-organizing systems with
the higher-order chemical language I
will be your narrator I am Karen Mayer
I'm also known on the internet as Giga
squid and I have recently written a book
by O'Reilly called living closure that
is a gentle introduction to the closure
programming language so you can check it
out and I also work at cognate Act so if
you ever come to any of my talks before
you know that I like to kind of start
things off with a little story so this
talk is no different so this starts off
with a little story of me cutting my
lawn I live in Cincinnati Ohio by a
river and it's a little bit rural I have
chickens and as a result I have a rather
large lawn to mow so I have a riding
lawnmower and I ride around on it and it
takes me a few hours to actually get a
cut but I really cherish this time
because this is time that I can just
unplug and be off of the internet and
all the other distractions actually just
think about things
so I usually like to pry myself before I
go out and mow the lawn and you know
maybe pick up a programming problem and
on this particular day I had just gotten
this new cool book called unconventional
programming paradigms by Springer
fabulous book and in it there is a
section of papers on this thing called
chemical programming or chemical
computing so I just like skimmed over it
really quickly and I started writing the
lawn mower and just thinking about this
so one more thing to let you know about
my lawn and my lawn mowing is I usually
wear a big hat because I have you know
fair skin and I burn easily so I wear a
big hat to cover my head and this works
great except in the case of tree
branches because we'll have this big
thing over my head
I sometimes misjudged the distance of
going under the tree branch and in this
particular day I did misjudge it and I
bonked my head and everything went blank
just for a second
but when when it came back like
everything was like fuzzy like I thought
it was like little dots you know it's
like after you hit your head and in this
moment you know brains are funny things
I think I still had a set of neurons
thinking about chemical programming and
what this means and I saw these dots all
at the same time and I saw them all over
the grass and I just thought whoa the
grass is computing and then I looked at
the tree and I was like whoa the tree is
computing and I looked at my hands and a
doctor but like I am computing and this
is true you know the grass is computing
the tree is computing you are computing
all living things process information
with chemical reactions on a molecular
level I mean we do this all the time
with our endocrine system with hormones
our immune system does this with
adaptive defense even just small
simple bacteria they do signal
processing of information so we're
computing all the time in the world is
computing all around us
so with this thoughts all in my mind I
went back in the house so my something
but don't wait I know you're thinking
you're saying are we going to be
actually programming with chemicals in
this talk so no although that would be
super cool too so in this talk we're
gonna be talking about abstract
chemicals we're going to actually be
using the metaphor of molecules
molecules and reactions to do computing
which is really cool in itself too so
wait what am I gonna get out of this
talk here's the exciting part you ready
I don't know and that's really awesome
because this talk is it's about cross
fertilization it's about cross
fertilization from two very different
fields from computer programming and
from nature and biology and when you
take two different fields like this and
see what you can learn from them you get
all sorts of research you get new ideas
and this is really where innovation
comes from this space and I will tell
you that chemical computing and chemical
programming right now is only in the
research domain I talked to one of the
authors of the paper and there's nothing
in the wild that he knows up yet and
this is really exciting in itself
because you all are extremely smart
people out there and I'm excited to see
you know when you listen to this what
might inspire you so let's talk about
chemical programming at the heart of it
all is all about the reaction so it's
kind of hard to explain without seeing
one way versus another way of doing
things so that's what we're gonna do
we're gonna compare two examples we're
gonna look at calculating primes the
traditional way that we're all familiar
with and then we're going to compute
primes with this new prime reaction way
of thinking about things
so first let's look at traditional
primes and this wait what is that
language with all the parens some are
you're thinking this is closure and the
first thing most important thing so how
many people are familiar with closure
okay great great a lot of people are for
the but for the people that are seeing
it for the first time from the
hitchhikers guide the closure don't
worry about the prince really they're
okay once you get an editor and you know
it matches the friends you can move back
and forth they really seem to disappear
so don't panic the friends are okay so
just a few words about closure as a
language it's a wonderful language I
really love it
it's dynamic so if you're defining a cat
you don't need to say what type it is
it's functional here we are we're
defining a simple function say hello
takes a parameter name that simply
concatenate a string hello with the name
you invoke that function by putting it
in the parens again say hello and then a
string molecule return
hello molecule it runs on the JVM so it
also has Java in wrap very nice job
enter up in fact the strings are just
java.lang strings if you're from the
Java world and you can invoke the
methods on them its supports concurrency
which is a wonderful thing as well it's
got a mutable data and it's got these
things called bars rafts adamant agents
that I'm not going to go into but I just
wanted to mention them and there's also
this exciting thing called closure
script now that lake's closure compile
down to JavaScript and go anywhere
javascript can go it has all the same
wonderful characteristics of closure but
it also has JavaScript Interop all right
so going back to our example let's go
ahead and take a look at computing
traditional crimes in closure so we
would define a function to figure out
whether something is prime or not and
we'll call it is prime question mark and
we give it a number so we could look at
all the possible factors of this number
from two up to the number and then we
can find its remainders you know and we
can see then are any of these remainder
zero if they're not that is prime so we
can look as is five prime yes is six
prime no we can go one step farther and
we can figure out generate some primes
so we can just take a range and you know
from two up to a hundred we can generate
all these numbers and then we can map
this function is prime over them and
filter out the ones that are only prime
and we're left with a list of primes up
to hundred so yeah you know this is all
very comfortable and familiar but how do
we do it with a prime reaction that's
what we're interested in so the first
thing you might notice is I have balls
on the screen and this is representing
molecules so we are going to think of
these numbers these integers as
molecules now and they're going to react
with each other so if you have a six
molecule reacting with a two molecule we
have a simple rule saying that if it's
divisible you can return a three and
then the two we can see this in code you
can take in a vector a list of these two
molecules we'll call them a and B and if
a is greater than B and if the mod of
the two together are zero
then we we could turn back a vector of
this a divided by B and the B otherwise
we'll just return unchanged the ones
that came in it would not react so we
could see the primary action of six and
two would return a vector of three and
two and the primary action of five and
two would just return unchanged that
five and two so then we can take can
define a whole bunch of these molecules
and we could define another function
that is going to mix and react these
molecules
so first we shuffle them all up because
we don't care what order they're in and
then we're going to partition them in
twos so go down the list and partition
them into x' and then we're just going
to go ahead and make them all react in
those pairs and they were just gonna
flatten out their return a vector and
that's gonna be our result so if we look
at the first ten from doing this mixin
act we can see hmm
well they're definitely maybe some
primes here but there's definitely not
some Prime's here so it's kind of hard
to tell exactly you know maybe doing
some work so maybe we need to do this
more time so we need to shuffle them up
and mix them up and react them more
times so let's make another function
called a reaction cycle and we can do
this n times and what it's going to do
is exactly that it's just going to go
ahead and mix and react then mix and
react them for n times so we can go
ahead and do this reaction cycle hundred
times and then peak at the ten first ten
our results and we get to see something
that looks a lot more like x resulting
so we can you do this even more times we
can do this with is at ten thousand
times and we can take a measurement of
our result and our measurement is going
to be we're gonna go ahead and take out
all the duplicates and sort them and lo
and behold we actually get some primes
it may have taken us a little bit more
time than the other Y but we actually
came to it from a totally different
angle and this way that we did this
actually has a name and it's called
gamma chemical programming and it's
composed of some things that we just did
it's got reaction rules and they operate
on multi sets of elements a reaction is
composed of two parts a condition plus
an action and then you execute these
rules and when you execute them you
replace the result elements with the
original elements
now here is the tricky part the result
is the solution when it reaches steady
state and that's kind of hard to predict
so we don't know exactly how many times
we have to mix them so let's look at
another example of nut crimes we can
also also calculate the maximum so again
look at our model click molecules we
have a six molecule and a two molecule
and this is gonna have the rule of
whoever's the biggest molecule we're
just going to return that two times so
it's going to return a six and A six now
we get to see a demo so I've done some
simulations of this enclosure script and
it uses core async so the important
thing about core acing is that it Abel's
concurrency oops
this one actually that's skipping ahead
okay so each molecule is saying is using
court async so each molecule is doing
its own thing and let me see if I can
make this a little smaller so you can
see it and we're gonna start it over
again so just a few words that the what
we're doing in code this is sort of a
visual representation the point of
having them in an XY coordinates is this
to help visualization and also to let
you know that nothing's happening in a
particular order so we have two
molecules and a two and a 20 and they
both bump into each other and they turn
into a twenty that's really cool that's
so that's what we saw but let's do more
Larry let's calculate the max of a
hundred using this alright this is a
little bit more interesting and you'll
see the balls actually change colors as
they kind of coalesce into groups and
you can actually see that here's the
measurements doing distinct and sort
down here so you can see there's groups
of 99 are the greens and there's a few
90s there's a 63 somewhere around
I don't know what's he doing but as they
react together they're coalescing into
an answer let me see there's an 83 oh I
see the 83 he's got a bump into somebody
it's not alright
oh there's you guys he bumped it there's
one more alone 97 yes the we calculated
the max with these little balls in a
gamma programming example and the answer
is 99 so there's other things you can do
to see what how am i doing on time I'll
just show you the Prime's real quick
because if Prime's are real cool too so
the same same thing as we were doing
before you can see as they react and get
together they start coalescing down to
the answer they don't have the the cool
color thing as the max so I'll I won't
do it too long but yeah when I first
came up with this demo I would just like
to spend way too much time looking and
I'm like wow anyway very much fun cool
let's get back to the presentation
where's my clicker so yeah so the next
thing you guys are thinking about I'm
sure all of you are thinking about is
higher-order what if we made the
reaction functions molecules too right
so if we had if we took that logic
extracted out of our presentation or out
of our program and we took it out and we
actually represented it as a molecule
and reacted those two what would happen
like so the function that we were using
they were talking about was Prime's that
has an area of two if that function
reacted with a number molecule it could
capture it as an argument and because it
has an area of two if that function with
a capture now element ran into another
molecule then it would capture it two of
them so this is really cool so
we have a function that has an area of
two it's captured these molecules as
it's reacted with them now what does it
do and this is a cool thing it actually
hatches and no I didn't make up this
term is actually in the paper
so the function molecule hatches out and
the result is the original function so
can go run around and interact with more
things and a three molecule and a two
molecule so what does this look like in
code this looks almost almost exactly
like the other code but it's now
embodied in that molecule so we have the
primary action that's now taking a
narrative two and a and a B and it's
doing the same sort of logic if a is
greater than the B and if it's a zero
then return a divided by B and B
otherwise return the molecules unreacted
the max reaction it looks even better
because it's shorter but you get taken
to two ERA T's or a already of two and
then a and B and then if a is greater
than B returned to A's otherwise again
the unchanged and B so let's see an
example of this if you have a function
molecule that has the max higher order
and you catch your attend and a for then
it's going to go ahead and hatch and
it's gonna have their original function
which is a max function and then two
tens so another cool thing we've seen is
we're always kind of taking in two
molecules and then resulting in two
molecules and the solution size is
pretty steady it doesn't change
but we can control that solution set
size by how many molecules we return so
if we return less we could call that a
reducing reaction function so with a max
you would take in two molecules a and B
and instead of returning the two you
could just return the bigger of the two
so if a is greater than B could just
return a otherwise you could return a
and B and this works we're just fine but
one of the problems is well I'll get to
that in just a minute let's look at the
the max row
quick so if you have a function and you
take in a ten and four then it would
just return that function in the 10 so
the problem that I was going to talk
about is that at least when I'm doing it
in this visual presentation it's really
hard because we've got a week for things
to bounce and interact together that it
takes a long time and sometimes things
don't end up bouncing with each other so
I ended up needing some more stirring
and my simulation to get things reacting
so I added one more rule that you can
allow functions to exchanged captured
values so what this means is if you have
to function molecules one that has
something captured in it and one doesn't
and if they bump into each other or any
react they can just go ahead and
exchange their captured values and this
just does some more stirring and lets
things react a little bit more so yeh
demo time
all right so let's start off with a
small max example so there's the 20 and
the 2 and I'm pointing my screen but
there's a function molecule as well and
I think the 20 is gonna go over here and
maybe bump into the function first and
it'll be captured and it's going to run
fat yes okay that's gonna capture the 2
and it's gonna hatch oh it got recapture
then rehashed but you can see the result
are the two 20s so yeah you're all
saying more now I want to see more I
know so let's see the max with the
function molecules and have them all
explode so when they hatch they kind of
like explode because I thought that was
kind of fun but you can see as they're
going along they are computing it takes
them a little longer to get to the
result than the the other one because
they have to be captured and the to
capture thing and then you know explode
and everything so it takes a little bit
more time but the beauty is is that we
have function molecules like floating
around here and interacting with stuff
we only have one function right now but
maybe we could put two you know we could
go crazy so and you can see that it's
slowly coalescing down to our answer
okay Oh run all the way but and you can
do the and I'm only going up to 50 and
not 100 just because with the function
molecules it gets a little bit busy but
so reducing primes I'll just let this
run for a few seconds so you can see it
so you can see if you let this run bet
that there's less and less molecules on
the screen and that's why you would be
the little extra stirring but it's all
just great fun
okay back to here
okay so what have we seen in these kind
of two examples well one thing that
really emerges is that there's no
sequential processing and that makes it
clear because these molecules are just
bumping around into each other at random
so that means that there's really no
order in things and that's interesting
because when you don't have sequential
processing you can really start doing
things concurrently and it's important
in other areas too if you in the keynote
that was fabulous you know that was one
of the things order
it's got hard in certain areas as well
so a typical problem for concurrency
which chemical programming can handle
quite well is something like the dining
philosophers per problem so who here has
heard of the dining philosophers oh
great great a lot of people okay so it's
another question for you well first
people haven't heard the dining
philosophers problem so these little
circles all around the table they're
supposed to be philosophers but I can't
like draw so you can just imagine
they're philosophers and the sticks in
between them this is a big question
Forks or chopsticks so raise your hand
if you think it's Forks all right if you
raise your hand if you took a chopsticks
all right I'm with the minority I said
it was Forks but so the the rule is for
the dining philosophers if it
philosopher is sitting at the table and
they have two forks available to them
they can pick it up and they can eat and
they become an eating philosopher if
they only have one fork or no Forks then
they need to be a thinking philosopher
and they have to continue thinking until
they have Forks available to them so how
do we model this in chemical programming
well with molecules of course so a the F
there is a fork it's a fork molecule and
the T P stands for a thinking
philosopher and the eat is an eat
molecule so so that's saying if a
thinking philosopher has two forks
available to them and it runs in it has
with an eating molecule then it turns
into an EP which is an eating
philosopher molecule
likewise if an eating philosopher
molecule runs into a think molecule it
will turn into and react a thinking
philosopher with two forks next to it so
of course you want to see the demo
alright so I can't do graphics very well
so I did them all on the line but I'm
sure it'll be okay
so if down here at the bottom you know
I'll point with my mouse you have yellow
is eating philosopher and then you have
TP is a thinking philosopher and then
you have the forks in between them and
the molecules are moving up in a random
order here they think and they eat and
they interact with each other and
they're just having a happy dining
experience
really and it makes a cool screensaver
too but it's really fun that you could
model such a problem with just simple
reactions and thinking about things as
molecules it's really a cool way to
think about things so back to the
presentation and with these simple
behaviors we can get some pretty
interesting properties we can combine
these simple behaviors and to
self-organizing systems we see this all
the time in nature as well right we see
ants doing this with ant colonies we see
bees doing this as well and we of course
see this all the time in mail systems
well we will so we could model a mail
system and have it be self-organizing by
using molecule example again so this
time we're going to have mailboxes mail
boxes on the mail servers are going to
be
regarded as molecules so you're gonna
have an in mailbox for a one and you're
gonna have on the other side and in
mailbox for b1 and in the middle you're
gonna have a network molecule and then
we're gonna have a mail message be
addressed to be one so it's going to
want to get over to the N mailbox b1 and
we're also gonna have another couple
molecules these are server molecules so
we're gonna have one for the a mail
system and we're gonna have one for the
B mail system and then we're gonna
introduce something new they're gonna be
membranes but the membranes aren't
really special they're just they're
molecules again but they're inert they
do not react with anything and the
purpose of the membranes is going to be
to separate molecules in the solution so
it kind of controls what they can
interact with so to put this in motion
we have our mail message wanting to get
over to be one and it bumps into the
membrane so no reaction because
membranes don't react with anything so
then it goes along memory array random
way and then it bumps into the mailbox a
one there's no reaction because there's
a rule there that says it only reacts if
it has a matching address and it's not
be one so then it goes on this merry way
and it reacts with server a and there is
a reaction here and this that's got a
very simple rule a stuff stays on one
side and if you're not that you just get
routed through the meta through the
membrane partition over the other side
so cool it has another simple reaction
very similar rules if you're not on the
a side you get routed across the way and
then it heads over to the server B again
it reacts shoves it over to the other
side and finally
eventually it'll bump into b1 and it
matches a dress and we have the reaction
and the mail was received so this is
really cool you know it very simple
simple behaviors and you can have a
self-organizing mail system but you can
take it further we can make this a
self-organizing and self-healing mailbox
or mail system because these simple
behaviors can combine to build resilient
systems so it can introduce another
molecule called a crash molecule and
this bounces around and whatever it
actually means the server molecule it'll
react with it and turn it into an
unhappy inactive Server molecule that
will no longer react with things or
acted the mail messages but happily we
can have a sentinel fix molecule that is
patrolling the area and just randomly if
it reacts with an inactive server
molecule it'll turn it into a
functioning server molecule again and it
can repair it so Wow let's see it in
action all right I'm gonna start this
I'm gonna make this big enough okay okay
so there's a couple crashes there's some
B messages over here oh it's ER they say
yeah there's B messages over here that
want to get over here and they're gonna
being routed through the a messages are
trying to get over this way oh so these
two are down eventually when this fixed
molecule gets over that'll fix something
yeah it prepared it there's one more
crash over here waiting to happen
but we can see actually that we did
actually receive some mail we got two
mail messages in a two already we got
one mail message in a one we just got a
couple more went into B b1 so stuff is
happening
hahahaha rates ma'am but yeah so this is
this is a really cool way to think of
things and again it's all just combining
these very simple reactions but don't
have any order to them that are actually
self-organizing and doing a interesting
I think behavior and I was late for
dinner a couple times just watching this
I was like I can't wait to let me a
message it's get in but yeah it's it's
all it's all just pretty cool alright
I'll stop watching it
I can be mesmerised okay
so what did we learn about this what did
I learn about this and my kind of
explorations of the papers and this
space well there's a few things right I
mean the the chemical programming is all
about reactions and it's really kind of
a nice way to get to the heart of the
things get to the heart of the logic
that you're trying to do with these
things that are reacting it kind of
makes it very simple make some simple
and elegant so I think that's got value
in itself the I think the most important
takeaway that I got from it is that it
really eliminates this incidental
sequentiality that we do every day I
mean most of our programming languages
we have lists of things and we turn vers
the list and we traverse lists in an
order and we loop over things and I
think we're so used to it that we forget
about it
it just becomes invisible to us and it's
nice to step back and think do we even
need that do we even need that
sequencing to do our job every day is
there another way to think about it and
take that out of the picture and I think
this can be important because when you
take this in quality out you can really
just open yourself up to concurrency
which is important in many places now
today so I think that's a real important
takeaway and also that these simple
behaviors they can combine and you can
really make robust systems with this we
saw this in a simple example with the
mailbox that again
they were just molecules they were
moving around but eventually they got to
the right place that they were supposed
to go they self-organizing system and
you could make them robust by having
other molecules that are standing around
ready to fix things if things go wrong
they don't have to have knowledge about
anything else going on they're just
doing their simple behavior and this of
course is you know we didn't make this
up this is all taken from nature and
this is what it's doing what this is
what nature is doing within us and
around us all the time and I think
there's a lot of lessons that we can
learn from nature and take and bring
over to the systems and the tools that
we build them with it so thank you all
if you're interested I have all the code
for these examples out on my github
along with the the demos so feel free to
you know explore and use the ideas so
that's it